schriftlich oder mundart das ist die
große frage in der schweiz verläuft
vielfältig und es gibt da und dort
heisig mundart oder hochdeutsch fördern
dass es eine jener fragen die sich
wollen nie abschließen wird beantworten
lassen über die sich aber lange und
trefflich streiten lässt die einen
lieben die mundart als schützenswertes
biotop die anderen stören sich am pult
des mündlichen mein kollege juri steiner
hat den germanisten peter von matt und
den berner schriftsteller pedro lenz
eingeladen zu einem klärenden gespräch
angesichts unseres komplizierten
verhältnisses zu sprache und sprechen
peter von marc pedro lenz grätz
miteinander größer wäre es vorstellbar
diese sendung auf mund zu halten darf
ich leicht sie zu fragen von matt als
graue eminenz der schweizer germanist ja
natürlich wäre das möglich wäre auch
spontan natürlich angenehm weil das ist
sozusagen die behagliche
form der verständigung in der schweiz
könnte mir allerdings vorstellen dass
wir in zusammenhänge kommen im gespräch
wo es dann wieder einfacher ist als
hochdeutsch probieren und für sie ja
mir fiel es bestimmt leichte montag zu
reden und wenn wir zusammen setzen der
garderobe forint so dann überlegen wir
uns das ja gar nicht dabei aber klar es
gibt immer situationen in der schweiz wo
sich die frage stellt was ist opportun
eigene situation ist zum beispiel ein
fernseher gespräch aber es ist eben
nicht nur unsere speziellen situation
sondern man merkt die schweiz die
deutschschweiz steckt in einer so
genannten mundart debatte es ist ein
sehr sensibles thema man merkt dass auch
wie sie ja wenn sie sich dazu äussern
hagelt es dann leserbrief und repliken
es polarisiert auch dieses thema und zu
dieser polarisierung haben wir eine
kleine situationsanalyse vorbereitet
doch er alle meine entchen oder anders
gefragt wie soll das kind innerschweizer
hinter gitter sehen
monatelang beherrschten die mundart
debatte die medien in der deutschschweiz
begonnen hat alles vor einigen jahren
mit der pisa studie die den
deutschschweizer schülern schwache
lesefähigkeiten attestierte
parlamentarier reichten einen vorschlag
ein um die schiff deutsch kompetenzen
der schüler zu verbessern
bereits im kindergarten sollte
hochdeutsch zumindest zum teil
pflichtsprache werden zu diesem
zeitpunkt waren bereits mehr als 200.000
deutsche in die schweiz eingewandert
hochdeutsch im kindergarten
die idee fand nicht bei allen anklang in
mehreren kantonen wurden
volksinitiativen gestartet die
schriftdeutsch im kinsky verbieten
wollten eine emotionsgeladene debatte
brach aus die intensität der partie
hatte natürlich damit zu tun dass
sprachen nicht einfach neutrale größen
sind sondern dass wir als sprecherinnen
sprecher mit sprachen dann auch gefühle
emotionen identitäten verbinden und in
der deutschschweiz ist es im moment so
dass einfach ganz viele mit schweizer
deutsch mit dialekt sprechen
verbinden sie ihre deutschschweizer
identität und ja so kann es dann kommen
im mai 2011 stimmte zürich als erster
kanton der dialekt initiative zu die
bildungsdirektorin regine aeppli dazu
kurz nach der abstimmung politischen
stimmung alle diese fragen eben wer sind
wir was ist unsere identität inwiefern
unterscheiden wir uns von anderen also
insbesondere natürlich auch denn den
deutschsprachigen einwanderinnen und
einwanderer habe diese frage lag
auch in der luft die debatte ist noch
längst nicht abgeschlossen
in mehreren kantonen sind weiterhin
mundart initiativen am laufen
gefühle emotionen die identität steckt
mittendrin in dieser grundproblematik
der montag debatte nämlich der
deutschschweizer identität signalisiert
diese 100 in erster linie eine
zugehörigkeit zu einer gruppe oder es
geht es schon um ausgrenzung hervor man
also identität ist ja ein sehr
schwieriges wort alle brauchen dessen
niemand weiß genau was du siehst aber es
ist ja zweifellos so dass wir in unserem
gefühl spontan gefühl den begriff des
schweizers der schweizer science mit der
mundart verknüpfen und von daher kommt
natürlich eine gewisse gefahr dass wir
gemeinde hat direkt als unsere sprache
bezeichnen und alles andere als nicht zu
uns gehörig während das eigentlich
interessante an der sprach situation der
schweiz ist diese hoch raffinierte
verbindung zweier sprachformen welcher
je eine andere bedeutung andere
funktionen haben und welche zusammen
funktionieren und ineinander greifen und
auf diese weise ein kommunikation
ermöglichen auf unterschiedlichen ebenen
das ist eigentlich das spezifisch
schweizerische aber für das spontane
empfinden ist das natürlich unsere
mundart weil wir bald auch sonst niemand
versteht und weil wir da gewissermaßen
unter umständen und rund sind wir quasi
in einer nische haben wir rheinischen
problem kann man als nischen eine
strategie macht und auch für die
schriftsteller lehnt sie schreiben auf
mundart sie sind sehr erfolgreich in
dieser mutter überraschend vielleicht
angst selbst für sie sogar denkt sie
dass wir ein nischen problem haben
da müsse man vorsichtig sein denn
es gibt auch eben reden 4 5 millionen
menschen auf der welt dieser sprache
aktiv brauchen und verstehen dass die
montag
ob das jetzt eine eine sprache ist der
dialekt können wir vielleicht später
noch darüber diskutieren aber
grundsätzlich wenn ich ein buch auf
deutsch schreibe gibt es potenziell fünf
millionen leute die das verstehen können
sogar noch im österreichischen und
deutschen grenzraum und das damit
reichlich mehr als beispielsweise was
ich ein litauischer autor der in seiner
sprache schreibt also es ist ein
bisschen ein irrtum zu glauben und da
haben wir schweizer manchmal auch die
missa in c spezielle seien die einzigen
die eine mundart haben und wir seien
eine minimal kleine minderheit
weil sie nicht wenige eine
großtechnische gewissermaßen aber bei
uns haben dass eine politische debatte
wir haben es gesehen eine heiße
politische debatte in der
bundesverfassung der schweizerischen
eidgenossenschaft steht nicht von nun da
das stück das heißt es gibt die
sprachfreiheit ist garantiert und dass
die landessprachen deutsch französisch
italienisch und rätoromanisch sein ging
da die mundart einfach vergessen
ein deutsch heißt einfach deutschmann
deutsche in der schweiz besteht aus zwei
formen des deutschen das eine ist das
schweizer hochdeutsch das zum teil sehr
viele eigene eigenschaften hat und das
andere sind ist nicht die mundart es
gibt ja auch die mundart nicht in der
schweiz sondern es gibt nur das ganze
spektrum der verschiedenen mandate und
das zusammen ist als deutsche in der
schweiz und die haben unterschiedliche
funktionen das eine werk geschrieben
dass andere wirkt gesprochen
das was mehrheitlich nur gesprochen wird
wird aber in einzelfällen auch wieder
geschrieben zum beispiel in der montag
kultur wurde ja die vertreter hier haben
aber deutsch heißt und dort nämlich die
bundesverfassung die auch deutsch
geschrieben ist wie gelangt das übrigens
nehme ich lieber mord die landessprache
ist deutsch
neben französisch italienisch und
rätoromanisch und deutsch heißt denn
nach die zwei fahren da ist die mundart
gut dann hätte man ist ja schon geklärt
und könnten aufhören zu sprechen
miteinander wenn man regionale zuhört
sagt man es geht beim deutschen ja doch
noch um etwas anderes auch es geht um
unser verhältnis zu diesen 200.000
deutschen einwanderern die bei uns sind
sondern um dieses vielleicht unwohlsein
gegenüber dieser sprachgewalt
sprachkompetenz der deutschen
einwanderer wie sehen sie das
das eigentlich regine zuhöre dann fällt
mir ja noch was anderes fällt mir auf
dass sie faul ist im reden und dann
frage ich mich ganz spontan warum kann
eine regierungsrätin die etwas sagen
muss dass nicht einfach direkt raus auf
montag sagen warum muss sie sich ins
gras ins korsett eine sprache begeben
die sie zwar kann die wir aber nicht so
gehört über die lippen kommt und das ist
das ist mein plädoyer für die mundart
ich will das nicht politisch verstanden
wissen sondern einfach rein menschlich
oder nicht hier sitze und hochdeutsch
schreitet dann mache ich das ich mache
das auch gärten ich habe überhaupt keine
sollte keine negativen gefühle dem
hochdeutschen gegenüber aber ich muss
mich viel mehr anstrengen und ich muss
ich muss die wörter länger suchen und
das hat einfach damit zu tun dass es
meine ich sage jetzt mal einfach mal
eine zweite sprache ist für meine
geschriebene sprache und da werde ich
mich dagegen dass man ein wenn man als
schweizer schweizerdeutsch spricht dann
sofort irgendwie in die in die
rechtsnationale ecke gedrückt wird würde
ich mache keine rolle da raus ich sag
nur wenn ich geld und wieder in bad
bertrich hören dass wir unsere
bundesräte in deutschland reden die
wirken hell sind und es gibt keinen
grund warum wir uns so hinstellen müssen
als die bauern oder aus die die nicht
die nicht intellektuell treten können
und wenn ich zum beispiel ein schweizer
politiker weit und es müsste mit angela
merkel eine fernsehdebatte führen dann
würde ich darauf bestehen dass ich 100
werden kann und dass sie besetzt wird
einfach um zu zeigen ich bin nicht halt
sind als du
während einer ansprache diese aktive
komplizierte zwischen mundart und
hochdeutsch reden wir noch zu sprechen
kommen aber es ist eben doch eine
politische debatte wenn man sagt ich
kann vielleicht zu fünf millionen
sprechen aber die anderen die lasse ich
aus es ist auch ein ein nationales
problem es gibt den genfer nationalrat
antonio hodgers zum beispiel der eine
ein katalog aufgestellt hat wann man wer
wie waren spricht bundesräte offiziell
immer nur hochdeutsch keine mundart es
gibt für vielleicht freiheiten bei der
sportübertragungen zum schwingen geht
sagt man mundart eine fußballübertragung
ist schon wieder hochsteigt und so
weiter also es ist eine gefahr die man
spürt auch schon national dass die
zunahme oder die die die bedeutung die
die mundart heute hat eine gefährdung
der nation des nationalen zusammenhalts
sein könnte ja ich glaube schon das
ganze ist ein einerseits ein
kulturpolitisches problem der schweiz
das verhältnis dieser zwei sprachform
und es ist auch ein politisches system
weil die schweiz aus vier vertretern
viel von vier landessprachen besteht die
miteinander kommunizieren müssen
und da gibt es da stellen sich einfach
fragen des verfahrens fragen der
sprachkompetenz des sprachgebrauchs ich
würde jetzt ich und finde jetzt da das
was pedro lenz gesagt hat nicht als so
bedrohlich mich stört es nicht wenn die
deutschen das gefühl haben da hatte
seine schwere zunge
das ist ein schweizer die haben die
schweizer ja längst im ohr und die
deutschen lachen zb über die sachsen
mehr als über die schweizer und die und
die bayern lassen über die berliner und
die berliner über die bayern also diese
sprache
dieser sprach verhöhnung innerhalb einer
sprache die gibt es auch
in deutschland und die gibt es übrigens
auch in der schweiz ist gehen wir diese
verspottung der gegenseitige stützung
der dialekte nimmt zum teil ganz scharfe
formen an
aber das politische probleme deshalb
scheint es mir das ist ganz wichtig was
diese genfer nationalrat
gemeint hat er wollte bewusst machen
dass es hier probleme gibt in dieser
überlagerung szene es gibt eine
überlagerung zone zwischen dem
selbstverständlich hochdeutsch
gebrauchten und zwischen
selbstverständlich gebrauchten dialekt
und da hat er eigentlich klarheit
gefordert und dann hat man in bern so
viel ich gehört habe sofort wieder
metern liegt ein wort von der sprache
des herzens gekommen
das ist nicht politisch gedacht das darf
jeder so empfinden für wie ich liebe den
100 auch und für mich ist er auch wenn
sie so wollen die sprache des herzens
aber das macht die geißen ich weiß wir
riefen in einer situation die so
kompliziert ist wie eine
hochkomplizierte uhr wo die räder
ineinander greifen und ergreifen diese
bilder ineinander geballten sprachen
aber das komplexe ist nicht immer das
einfach und gerade in politischen
debatten geht es nicht um die grauwerte
sondern um schwarz und weiß und wenn man
spürt dass man eben hochdeutsch und
dialekt in der politischen debatte sehr
gut gegeneinander ausspielen kann
offensichtlich funktioniert das haben
wir auch vielleicht ein thema innerhalb
der schweiz in der deutschen schweiz
zwischen stadt und land vielleicht auch
gibt es dass sie all ends sie sind über
200 mal im jahr habe ich gelesen sind
sie an auftritten
sie bereiten also pedro lenz ist überall
in der schweiz wie nehmen sie das wahr
wenn sie auf dem auf dem teller sind
also es gibt natürlich verschiedene wie
soll ich sagen
verschiedene zugänge zum montag es gibt
leute die sagen die sagen wir dann eine
lesung aber das ist jetzt schon dass sie
was in jedem schönen dialekt machen und
dann sage ich
ich habe keinen begriff von schönheit
für einen dialekt also für mich gibt es
nichts schöneres und weniger schöne
dialekt schöne und weniger schöne
sprache sondern es ist das system nur
eine frage der ausformung nicht aber ich
habe mal sich leute die kommen weil es
monat ist aber dann gibt es auch um das
hoffe ich sehr viele liga tour
interessiert der was sich natürlich
merke ist beispielsweise es gibt dinge
die man nicht politisch regen kann und
beispielsweise die höflichkeit die kann
man nicht politisch regeln oder mieter
eines sagt ich verstehe kein
schweizerdeutsch landräte ich mit ihm
auch deutschland mit 1
ein genfer sagt die versteck kein
schweizerdeutsch schon weil es unhöflich
weiter schweizerdeutsch zu reden
das ist das eine aber das ist natürlich
auch ich kann mit mundart literatur kann
nicht mehr experimentieren kann ich habe
ich andere freiheiten und wenn ich aufs
land raus gehen dann kriege ich manchmal
auch negative rückmeldungen von leuten
die sagen man sieht also der direktor
der sektion montag
dieser begriff fertig dann ist nicht so
dass sie haben das falsch gesagt haben
gesagt auf englisch aber korrekt wäre
unmoralisch und dieses falsch wichtig
aber nicht ein bisschen entspannter denn
ich denke ich mag sprachen und ich lese
viel und ich interessiere mich versprach
für sprachwissenschaft aber ich kann den
leuten nicht vorschreiben wie sie die
ebenso ihr erfolgsbuch von dem sie
zeichnet sich ein bisschen gesprochen
der goalie bieniek können sie uns etwas
kurzes als vorletzter mit ein bisschen
spüren was sie meinen wenn sie von ihrer
sprache
wenn ich kann natürlich auf hochdeutsch
landes rhythmisieren als beispielsweise
ein
wie soll ich sagen nein wenn ich das
hochdeutsch machen müssen weil ich das
weniger morgen habe ich gebe ein kleines
beispiel da schon grundschüler extrem
komisch der kritische frau sieht jahren
unter belastung gar nicht so viel ruhm
plötzlich unter dirk plötzliches bis mal
plötzlich zieht bis ultimate force macht
plötzlich gefahr dass er nur noch wild
wird also ich kann das natürlich auch
auf deutsch schreiben aber das ist nicht
das problem dass man man kann jeder
sprache übersetzen
aber ich habe da stimmen ihm aber nicht
schnell bei und jede sprache hat die
eine ein bisschen eine melodie einen
sound und und dann versuche ich dann
nachzubilden das ist ein künstlicher
prozess mache ich das natürlich ist eine
sprache des herzens die die die
direktheit die politische debatte die
kinder sprache und dass sich das ganze
so stark auf dieser kindergarten debatte
ausgebreitet hat hat es sicher auch
damit zu tun dass das eben hoch
symbolisch ist also was sprechen kinder
wie werden kinder angesprochen sie sind
unschuldig sie ihre identität wird noch
gebildet ist das eine debatte die eine
schweizer tradition ebenso entgegenläuft
dass man sagt es geht quasi montag wir
lieben es etwas was mit mentalität zu
tun hat dann plötzlich ist das ideologie
mit politik
ja also grundsätzlich ist es so dass wir
in der schweiz in den ersten 20 jahren
in diese zwei sprachformen hineinwachsen
wir lernen beide wobei wir das
hochdeutsche natürlich normiert
jahrhundert ist nicht noch mehr deshalb
ist es uns ja sowohl in monza hat
während wir recht scheibe fehler können
wir nur dem hochdeutsch zu machen
deshalb empfinden wir das hochdeutsche
aus die schwiegermutter sprache aber das
ist seit zweieinhalb tausend jahren kann
die menschheit schreiben und seit 2000
jahren muss sie schreiben lernen und
schreiben lernen ist eine anstrengung
der prozess aber dass man einst in der
schweiz die tatsache das schreibenlernen
ein anstrengender prozess ist der montag
in die schuhe schiebt und sagt das war
das richtige
das ist einfach ein denkfehler das ist
einfach falsch
die die debatte mit dem kindergarten
auch die interessiert muss sich seine
interessiert mich überhaupt nicht ich
hatte einen so grauenhaften kindergarten
ist so langweilig so unendlich
langweilig von mir aus können sie im
kindergarten kisuaheli reden wenden
wollen aber die kinder soll es lustig
haben und die kinder sollen lernen wie
sie miteinander auskommen
wenn die mal lernen wie sie miteinander
auskommen dann bleiben sie auch wie sie
miteinander reden müssen
diese ganze debatte war das hochdeutsche
anfängt und wie lange der dialekt
unbedingt nur direkte und was auch immer
dass ich finde das ist völlig daneben
das ist etwas für die didaktik für die
erzieher und die pädagogen der finden
alle zehn jahre neue grundmodelle und
dann müssen alle bücher schulbücher
umgeschrieben werden
aber das interessiert mich selber
überhaupt ist aber das format ich glaube
ja nicht dass ein täter baute das
problem ist dass die leute sagen auch
deutsche schwierig also das braucht viel
viel anstrengung also sollten sie doch
montag schreiben das ist einfach sondern
ich glaube das problem ist die dass das
wegen dieser unsäglichen pisa-studie die
behauptung im raum steht wir könnten zu
wenige seien nicht sprach kompetent
genug weniger sprach kompetent als
unsere nachbarn und schuld daran sei die
mundart und da fängt es an dass man wie
die beiden fordern gegeneinander
auszuspielen beginnt und ich bin der
überzeugung im kindergarten da könnte
ich das unterschreiben was sie gesagt
haben aber ich bin der überzeugung dass
es ganz bestimmt nicht förderlich ist
ein moment und sagt du sprichst falsch
ich habe das gerät bei schulbesuchen es
ist furchtbar schwieriger eine
schulklasse einfach von 14 jährige
pubertierenden die zu motivieren dass
sie fragen stellen und dann mache ich
eine lesung dann kommt ein mit allen
fragen schüchtern aber durchdachte frage
und hat endlich den mut gefasst und der
leerung von hinten auch deutsche sind im
deutschunterricht und dann sagte er
wieder rein weil er wieder eins auf den
deckel gekriegt hat und das führt nicht
zu mehr freude an der sprache ich
plädiere für mehr leichtigkeit mehr
spielerischen umgang und nicht ich finde
das auch uns eigentlich dass man das
projekt gestanden weil er mit
abstimmungen in der regel tun so ich
hatte doch als er die vorfreude der wenn
es die leserinnen hochdeutsches gedicht
vor gesagt hat warum weil man plötzlich
merkt als kleinlich kam mit den sprachen
spiele nicht kann hin und her wechseln
und so weiter ein rennen kann aber noch
das spanische zur eine dritte
muttersprache also sportlich war
eigentlich die erste sprache in der sie
leben gelernt haben dann relativ rasch
weil ich an der schweiz aufgewachsen
relativ rasch kamen diese beiden
deutschen wurden dazu aber zu hause mit
der mutter haben wir immer nur spanisch
gesprochen und mein vater der schweiz
war das auch
ob es auch gelernt weil er wollte dass
eigene sprache zumeist gesprochen und
dann kam das schweizerdeutsche auf der
straße und dass auch deutsche dass mir
vorgelesen wurde
und ich glaube nicht dass die kinder ein
problem damit haben sondern vielleicht
hat die svp eines oder das weiß ich
nicht aber die kinder haben sich zuletzt
ein problem damit
ich finde das sehr wichtiges gesagt hat
dass beide sprachformen eben ein hohes
spielerisches und lust haltiges
potenzial aber ich sehe das an meinen
enkelkindern die heutigen schweizer
kinder deutschschweizer kinder die
lernen ja das hochdeutsche passiv
verstehen sehr sehr viel über die
fernsehsendungen die kindersendung die
können zum teil die können zum teil
hochdeutsch ganze textpassagen herunter
schnell war in absolut perfekte bühne
hochdeutsch und die lieben das die
lieben auch das wird zwischen hin und
her und dieser spielerische fröhliche
umgang mit dem sprachformen das finde
ich etwas sehr wichtiges denn dass das
vertreibt dann auch später die
vorstellung man sei irgendwie hand die
kapiert als schweizer wenn man
hochdeutsch spricht aber wenn man sich
mit dem hochdeutschen beschäftigt ich
bin überzeugt noch nie in der geschichte
haben die deutschschweizer hochdeutsch
so perfekt verstanden wie heute und zwar
in allen deutschen varianten vom
hamburgischen bis zum wienerischen weil
sie ja immer den tatort räumen und alle
diese verschiedenen sie hören das 60
bei einem psychiater und so weiter sie
kennen das und sie schauen dass auch
gern aber es ist da kommt wieder ein
pferdefuß herein weil man jetzt so gut
weiß wie diese deutschen reden
bis in die letzte geschlossenheit hinein
empfindet man sich selber als
schwerfälliger aus man tatsächlich isst
dann wenn ich wie deutschen rede was man
verstehen die einer meinung man spricht
miteinander und dann ist das wenden aber
ich glaube es gibt dabei es gibt beides
sei zu haben wir dadurch dass wir
dialekt reden und dass wir auch so viele
so viel mobilität haben und überhaupt
gegenseitig dialekte hören denn von 100
jahren hat vielleicht ein nidwaldner nie
gehört wenn wallis spricht aus die
vielleicht einmal in seinem leben und
wir hören dass sie auch ständig dadurch
haben wir diese kompetenz verschiedene
sprachen und zu unterscheiden wir nicht
in in schottland ein wort ein bisschen
falsch betont beim taxifahrer dann
versteht nämlich nicht mehr und wie mit
so vielen ausländern die gebrochen
deutsch reden wir haben die fähigkeit
ganz viele varianten des deutschen zu
verstehen oder kreativ zu ergänzen
würden die fehler auszubügeln im ort und
das sollte man vielleicht ein bisschen
mehr in den vordergrund heben und nicht
ständig von den defiziten reden aber ich
habe natürlich schon ein bisschen eine
behinderung nicht eine große aber eine
leichte behinderung beim beim freien
regen oder aber damit hätten jetzt quasi
mal unsere unser verhältnis zum
hochdeutschen ein bisschen harmonisiert
aber ihre dezidierten aussagen zu dieser
debatte der muttersprache in zwei
varianten die heftigsten reaktionen
haben sie nicht wegen dem hochdeutschen
bekommen sondern wie sie unserem und
acht definieren und sie schreiben zum
beispiel der verbreitete waren nur
dialekt sei muttersprache der
deutschschweizer beruht auf einer
mischung von denk schwäche
sentimentalität und borniertheit und da
haben es natürlich reaktionen
verstehen sie das
natürlich ich meine das war ein dieser
text im tages anzeiger
das war ein ausschnitt aus einem drei
mal so langen artikel der am anfang sehr
munter und vergnügt die dass das
schweizer hochdeutsch charakterisiert
hat und die schwierigkeiten im umgang
mit dem schweizer hochdeutschen
deutschen hochdeutsch dargestellt hat
dass das eine eigene sprache ist der
schweizer hochdeutsch nicht hoch doch es
ist nicht die sprache in der deutschen
ist unser sprache auch hat das
dargestellt und am schluss habe ich dann
das ist sein
das war ein text für für einen verlag
vierteln verlags almanach des diogenes
verlags und am schluss habe ich dann so
ein bisschen los gelegt und gesagt also
es ist eigentlich die schweizer sagen
das ist das richtige monat ist die
eigene sprache und alles andere ist uns
fremd und haben wissen auf den putz
gehauen und dann hat der die zeitung
gesagt ob sie diesen polemischen schwanz
des artikels abdrucken dürfe und ich
habe weiter darüber nicht nachgedacht
und die haben das abgedruckt haben wären
ganz bösen titel eingesetzt der nicht
von mir stammt der auch nicht meine
meinung ausdrückte und dann ist das los
gegangen aber das phänomen dieses podest
sturms das ist natürlich interessant ich
meine warum werden die leute denn so
wütend man nimmt ihnen ja nichts weg
aber es scheint ihr ein diffuses problem
zu bestehen und ich vermute das problem
besteht eben darin dass man sich über
der überzeugung ist die richtige die
ware sprache meine richtige und rade
sprache ist meine mutter hat und alles
andere wird mir befohlen und ausgestellt
wie dem rost
er sackt indes tragen muss und dadurch
kommt dieses diese animosität herein
statt dass man sieht dass das eine
unglaubliche chance ist eine sprache zu
haben hinter mundart die man nicht
schreiben muss die man nicht die man
schreiben kann wie man will wo es keine
regeln gibt wo man nicht gegrillt werden
muss und dann eben die andere wo man
zwar geteilt wird aber wo man dann den
zugang
teilhaber ist einer der großen kultur
sprachen der ganzen welt das ist eine
unglaubliche chance und wenn man daraus
jetzt sozusagen ein antiker konstruiert
dann ist das irgendwie falsch gedacht
ich respektiere diese empfindungen
aber ich glaube die sind irgendwie
falsch gemacht
ich habe eben den eindruck dass diese
soll ich sagen
diese analyse an universitäten noch
diese dieses handicap diese diese
gedanken nur die mundart ist meine
richtige sprache das ist eine
trotzreaktion auf ganz viele das
natürlich auch für einen einbruch der
schweizer ist deutschschweiz ist was man
nicht begeistert auch zum beispiel
dieser nationalrat hodges den ich sehr
schätze der übrigens auch ein spanischer
sprache ist dann ist ein
auslandschweizer der kommt natürlich
auch quasi mit der forderung entspreche
falsch oder und diese idee dass oder
wenn man einem kind sagt du sprichst
falsch diese idee die einzigen ich
glaube die einzigen in europa die die
sich entschuldigen für die der
muttersprache sind wie mit die sich
inzwischen bei jedem deutschen georgia
kann nicht so gut braucht halt die vom
westschweizer kritisiert werden weil sie
nicht sofort mit ihnen hoch david treten
das sind wir und das problem zum
beispiel wenn es jetzt um die
verständigung innerhalb der schweiz
gingen die die sagen ja de seit
unhöfliche seit rüttehof geräte nicht
gut hochdeutsch mit den menschen die
endlich mal auf deutsch gelernt haben
und uns natürlich kommen und das nicht
verstehen dann sage ich da liegt das
problem weniger das problem liegt darin
dass wir aber das ist dann wieder ein
anderes thema das wir heute alle früh
englisch lernen wollten alle den schulen
aufzwingen wollen statt die stadt sich
bewusst zu werden dass wir dass wir uns
gegenseitig die landessprachen
beibringen sollten das war viel weil wir
hier sind die schriftsteller immer so
gut
grenzgänger doppel spione in dieser
beziehung zwischen der mundart und dem
hochdeutsch und und sie beschreiben dass
in vielen aufsetzen
schön wie ich weiß nicht gotthelf der
der wirklich sein sein berndeutsch in
seinen in die deutsche literatur hinein
gehört hat und das geht dann so weit
dass vielleicht deutsche leser in
deutschland manchmal meinen sie lebten
schon mundart wenn sie hofft also
deutsch schweizer schriftsteller in
deutsch lesen
es gibt diese spiele auch dass man sich
freut dürrenmatt sicher dass eines der
besten beispiele es gibt eine anekdote
von ihm erhoffen sich durch einen
vortrag gehalten hat auf hochdeutsch und
dann hat ein zuhörer aus dem publikum
hat geschrieben
hochdeutsch bitte weil das war so durch
die mundart gefärbt und dann habe
dürrenmatt einfach gesagt ich kann nicht
hören
und da sind wir jetzt quasi nicht mehr
in einer politischen debatte sondern
einer kulturellen und die das
wohlbefinden in diesem hochdeutsch hängt
von der kultur ab auch also an diesen
leitfiguren die uns zeigen dass man mit
dieser sprache auch glücklich werden
kann ja glücklich und die dürfen markt
hat ja eigentlich kaum je ein wort in
dialekt geschrieben aber der hat seine
ganze leidenschaft war dass die
literarische sprache die hochdeutsche
sprache auf dem höchstmöglichen niveau
die alle nach unten eben gleich kommt es
gelegentlich einen dialekt onlineshop
ersten kriminalroman kommend mal
besoffen singenden gestartet
wenn wir jetzt acht reduziert da kommen
diese einschübe aber daneben daneben
geht es dann im hochdeutschen in der
deutschen literatur sprache die zu den
führenden kultur sprachen der welt
gehört eben weiter und durch das
hochdeutsche haben wir eine literatur
die gleichzeitig mit der literatur
österreichs und deutschlands ist jetzt
ein verzeichnis gekommen
heraus gekommen über den verkauf der rec
der mitte meist verkauften arikan bücher
seit dem krieg marica ist der
meistverkaufte taschenbuch verlag das
meistverkaufte ist wilhelm tell von
schiller war ein haupt französisches
werk durch das zweite der faust von
goethe das dritte eine erzählung von
gottfried keller also die literatur der
schweiz gehört kann es zentral zur
deutschen literatur deutsche literatur
ist nicht die literatur der deutschen
sondern da leute die deutsche sprache
regen wie wir und die dialekt diktatur
der schweiz wie petra lenz schreibt zum
teil schreibt das hat mir auch anderes
geschrieben
die gehört auch dazu weil es auch in der
ganzen deutschen sprache landschaft
große und großartige texte im regionalen
direkt gibt also diese beiden formen
gibt es überall aber wir gehören dazu
und die schweizer schrift seiner
entwicklung entweder wie gotthelf der
eine spezifisch hoch raffinierte sprache
der verquickung von hochdeutsch und
dialekt geschrieben hat oder andere die
konnte kein nur striktes hochdeutsch
schreiben aber das sind verschiedene
formen aber das gehört das ist dann
alles teil des gewaltigen künstlerisch
gewaltigen kosmos den wir deutscher
literatur nennen gotthelf an eine oder
zwei kleine geschichte ganz winzige
texte nur im dialekt und ein gedicht das
einzige gedicht dass ich von gotthelf
kenne ist in dialekt das ist ein frauen
liedchen ich weiß niemand
das ist ein wunderbares gedicht marita
keine höhere gruppe hatte nicht am park
verwünscht hatten eine klare bewertung
ich glaube es ist ein bisschen wie mit
allem leben mit mit der schweiz in der
deutschen schweiz
wir können unser im leben bei allem auf
die defizite fokussieren darauf auf den
gewinnen nicht wenn wir ein leben deuten
und als auch dort kann ich natürlich ein
leben lang nie haben und sagen mein
hochdeutsch ist nicht gut genug
ich möchte ich viel besser ist und bin
trotzdem noch nicht der rockband ortet
wird können uns freuen und sagen wir
haben wieder eine pole der wir haben das
sorgt deutsches wird in der schule
gelernt haben und dass wir täglich lesen
denn wir lesen ja das haben wir heute
noch gar nicht gesagt will ist ja keine
mundart zeitungen in der schweiz noch
nicht und auch die bücher sind zu 99
prozent hochdeutsch aus
das steht uns zur verfügung dann noch
die mit dialekt anregungen dann die
verschiedenen sounds darüber haben wir
die noch wenig gesprochen also die
sprachmelodie und und aus diesem
reichtum gibt es dann auch ein reicher
literatur wenn ich noch etwas beifügen
man darf ja nicht meinen dass die
schweizer schlechteres schreiben als die
deutschen sagt lust in einem ihrer
aufsätze dass sie bei den dialogen
probleme haben ja es gibt bereiche wo es
schwieriger ist aber jetzt ich meine
jetzt nicht nur nicht in der literatur
sondern auch sonst ich habe mein leben
lang an der universität unterrichtet ich
habe immer arbeiten korrigiert und
besprochen mit den studierenden und die
und es gab immer auch viele deutsche die
in zürich studiert haben und die die
seminararbeiten der deutschen die waren
nicht besser geschrieben einem besseren
deutsch nicht marina fehlerlos die
schweizer studenten die haben absolut
genau gleich gute sprachlich gute texte
abgeliefert wie die deutschen und hatte
nicht weniger nicht mehr fehler
die deutschen machen andere fehler als
die schweizer aber das ist genau ich
werde das schweizer schulsystem ist ja
sehr gut aus ganzes und wer da hindurch
gegangen ist der kante und der kann
deutsch schreiben sowie
irgend ein deutscher deutsch schreiben
kann
ich würde gerne noch einmal ein bisschen
auf diese mundart welle oder die
aktuelle zurückkommen die so ich weiß
nicht wie sie statistisch ist das genau
erfasst ist aber offensichtlich raum
greift ihn ja auch in anderen
kulturellen gattungen also nicht nur in
der literatur aber empfehlen dann
natürlich radio fernsehen sind sind
bereiche die musik die populärmusik ist
ist sehr stark geprägt indem er das eben
dort ist von von sound das hat etwas mit
straßenkultur zu tun glaubwürdigkeit
profitieren und sie unmittelbar von
diesen dialekt welle wenn sie jetzt habe
ich konnte das natürlich nicht
beurteilen und ich würde umgehend sagen
dass ich von einer welt profitiert weil
ich gern gehören würde das hätte dass
die bücher auch ohne welle gut werden
aber was natürlich klar ist und von
meiner seite sein ist es gibt eben in
der literatur den bereich der
nachgeahmten mündlichkeit und da haben
wir schweizer wirklich ein bisschen
defizit weil wir nicht ganz genau dieser
kollekte kennen die wir beschreiben wenn
ich zum beispiel nehmen wiederum ich
mache einen gauner roman in deutschland
heute so kleine so klein und die sich in
der kneipe treffen
irgendwo ein bauernhof an einem
bierstand und ich will dir reden lassen
in einem raum haben dann weiß ich nicht
genau wie ich die reden lassen soll dann
habe ich mir die eine möglichkeit ist
ich beschreibe das indirekte rede das
hat viel gemacht
die andere möglichkeit ist ich betreibe
ich suche eine völlig konform
das peinlichste aber ist wenn ich mit
meinem kleinen tatort hochdeutsch west
versuche die in einem slum reden zu
lassen wenn sagen sie immer nur machen
und scheiße und und deshalb
kann ich diese dinge die familie
beschreibungen viel viel weiß erfurt
machen das gleiche
ähnlich geht es einem wahrscheinlich
einem rocksänger da gibt es ein paar
pointen darunter wie kuno lauener
der hatte einen sound der den mann in
baden hört und zwar ein sound eine
generation und eine schicht und vertrieb
und das dafür ist im umbau eignet und
dem film ist deshalb das gleiche wieder
haben schweizer firmen dagegen die und
bauen die im stau einem verderben eine
runterhauen hat das und wie wollen wir
das auch fragt euch machen wir wissen
wenn wir die kenntnisse nicht haben wir
wurden in deutschland die ihre kinder
schlagen in welcher sprache die das
machen
dann bietet es sich an dass im montag zu
machen aber es war dann muss man
natürlich jetzt wieder das stimmt da
stimmt man das ist das große das
dauerproblem der schweizer
schriftsteller die hochdeutsch schreiben
dass sie jung ansprache montag ist und
dass sie keine selbstverständliche
umgangssprache für die ihre texte zur
verfügung haben sie müssten sie
eigentlich künstlich herstellen
das ist aber ein challenge der sogar zu
künstlerischer vierten formel führen
kann
hunderte ein rettet die sache nicht ein
großer teil der schweizer filme die
mundart sind um zurecht mundart sind
wieso uns nicht weiter und auch filme
geben die sind aber hinein und da sind
die dialoge so miese haben so trostlos
nur mit mundart ist noch kein guter
dialog bargeld sowie mundart noch keine
durch rhythmisierte großer seite da ist
wie sie sie vorher vorgelesen
die eigentliche künstlerische arbeit die
ist auch bei der mutter erfordert und
das ist die verblendung die viele auch
viel mehr machen
andere haben 100 umgehen dass sie denken
mundart ist allein schon daran und da
kann jeder 100 ist kein gegenstand der
gestaltung sondern die das kommt einfach
so und dann kommen diese trostlosen
dialoge heraus die dann die ganzen filme
zum teil kaputt machen dass ich meine
jetzt nicht eine verschiebung der
bedingung ist der hat mich auch
überrascht über die durch die präzision
mit der burg magath gesetzt war das ist
eine große künstlerische leistung
aber es gibt andere die dann zu einem
feld wald und wiesen direkt mit
hochdeutschen formulierungen und
strukturen das sehen wir die gefahr dass
die hochdeutschen syntax satzstrukturen
durchdrücken
die das dann so machen also da gebe es
tage im bereich der dämmung gar dialoge
gäbe es eine menge zu tun auch bei
unserer medien und das würde dann in
letzter konsequenz wenn man das gut
machen könnte dass man sich shakespeare
auf toggenburg ist vorstellen könnte
ja das kann man schon machen ich sehe
nicht ein warum weil man ihn ja es gibt
gute übersetzungen und man kann ihn so
erfahren und so erleben aber wenn jemand
das gerne macht ja warum nicht das ist
es geht dann natürlich es ist dann der
ganze shakespeare der aufseher
verschiedenen sprachen spricht der zum
teil den hohen ton hat das große
partners die großen reden im hohen
pathos das können sie nicht auf montag
gewundert ist sie ihr reich aber sie hat
eine begrenzte bandbreite also kein
vollständiges literarisches system ja
ich glaube das muss man so sagen
sie ist nicht denn sie besitzen nicht
ein vollständiges elektronisches system
aber sie besitzt
natürlichkeit zu absoluten hydraulischen
spitzenwerken im dialekt und zwar immer
dann und immer dort je näher der
betreffende text der direkten rede ist
also das ist sehr bezeichnend das ist
ein ausgezeichnetes buch von peter lenz
aber es ist ein buch ein roman der
eigentlich ein eine fortwährend der rede
eines bei einer bestimmten figur
darstellt und diese figur wird immer
komplexer und immer differenzierter
indem ich sie reden höre aber andere
literarische verfahren bei anderen
elektrischen fahren wird was dann rasch
relativ schwierig aber solange die
dialekt literatur im umkreis der direkte
rede der kohlequalität der dialoge
bleibt hat sie natürlich alle
möglichkeiten zu den zu spitzenwerke der
welt liegt dass ich glaube das problem
ist ein bisschen da sagen eine tradition
fehlt also es gibt eine kleine montag
tradition ist hat mich dass es keine
gibt dabei einfach nicht die gleiche
kann nicht auf werke aus mitleid
zurückgreifen oder aber trotzdem bin ich
da mal weniger pessimistisch rauber man
kann eigentlich in jeder sprache alles
machen natürlich es gibt bei den halten
diese unterteilung von netzliteratur
haben im stil mit ihrem stil und und
mieter um stil und und da gibt es halt
in der montag keine für deinen haben
stil keine tradition hat man könnte die
künstlich brauchen warum nicht mich
persönlich interessiert das wenig labors
ich behaupte und da und da bin ich
überzeugt davon ist dass man in jeder
sprache alles machen kann und auch in
der montags machen kann denn weil es
nicht so würden ja zum beispiel
professoren der physik sagen wir mal
oder professoren der linguistik wenn sie
an einem tisch sitzen und diskutieren im
café oder auf der bundesräte würden ja
dann im gespräch
irgendwann sagen du jetzt wird das thema
ein bisschen zu heikel banken geld und
zulassungs auf hochdeutsch wechseln und
das machen sie ja nicht also ich glaube
nicht dass die bundesweit wenn sie
kaffeetrinken auf deutsch schreiben und
rechnen wenn sie es wenn sie es
formulieren müssen für deinen
pressecommuniqué tanja aber also
willkommen im dialekt auf alle höhen
wenn wir das wollen
ja wenn die bundesräte wenn sie zusammen
ein bier trinken
die reden ja da nicht in der gleichen
sprache in der sie nun zb denn beim tod
eines bedeutenden schweizer geräte
halten müssen oder so das ist alles
schon möglich natürlich kann man das
aber man es hat keinen sinn dass man
diese grenzen verwischt das interessante
ist ja die situation in der schweiz zu
studieren zu studieren was sind die
chancen für die mundart literatur und wo
liegen die grenzen oder die
schwierigkeiten es geführte monat
literatur das ist das ziel dass das viel
interessanter die literatur ist ein
bereich aber es gibt ja auch noch einmal
so etwas wie die ganz normale bewegung
auf der straße überall die
verschriftlichung der mundart ist ein
phänomen das nicht nur jetzt ganz kleine
gruppen mehr betrifft kasten sprache der
jugendsprache
auch dafür haben wir eine kurze analyse
vorbereitet wir uns anschauen können ob
zürich basel oder bern die mundart ist
heute in der deutschschweiz die sprache
der jugend
die jugendlichen und kinder reden nicht
nur so wie sie denken sie schreiben
neuerdings auch so wie sie reden seit
langem läuft die private schriftliche
austausch ob sms e mail chat oder
postkarten fast nur in mundart dialekt
wird bei ihnen immer mehr zu einer
parallelen schriftsprache geht geht
davon aus dass die jungen in einer art
von zwei schriftlichkeit aufwachsen dass
sie zwei jahrzehnte schreibens haben
also schreiben im dialekt schreiben in
hochdeutsch und dass es für sie in der
zwischenzeit nur mal ist eben diese
beiden schienen zu haben wie man sich
das sonst eigentlich von der möglichkeit
gewollt ist das gab es so noch nie
bereits ist die erste generation mit
dieser zwei schriftlichkeit groß
geworden
sie kennen es nicht anders und sie
werden älter
dass sie in zukunft ihre schreib
gewohnheiten ändern ist kaum zu erwarten
möglicherweise wird das einfach zu einem
normalzustand oder ein zustand der die
ganze gemeinschaft betrifft das man
einfach so
zwei arten des schreibens hat und dass
das nicht mehr unbedingt so ein jugend
sprachliches merkmal ist sondern eins
das dann die deutschschweizer sprecher
gemeinschaft mit einer unterteilt dass
das alles so machen eben informelles
wird dialekt geschrieben formelles wird
auch deutsch gering vielleicht die
zukunft wird es zeigen
wagen sie eine zukunftsprognose herum
nein ich finde das sind ja alles jede
sprache ist in einem ständigen wandel
begriffen sprach ist das unglaublich
dynamisches und wenn sie die dialekt
situation in der schweiz betrachten ist
ja auch innerhalb der dialekt ist eine
menge in bewegung denken sie an die an
die veränderungen die justiz
eingewanderten zustande kommen und so
ist auch diese entwicklung über die
neuen medien über die eifersucht und die
hand ist und die sms dass da sich diese
100 schriftsprache entwickelt das ist
ein hoch interessantes phänomen aber das
ist immer noch ein
phänomen eben in der großen
nebeneinander der beiden grundformen des
deutschen die wir in der schweiz haben
und das zeigt dass diese beiden formen
in einem beständigen kreativen austausch
zueinander stehen und nur wenn man
worauf pedro lenz folgen hingewiesen hat
wenn man anfängt immer zu sagen dass
dieses falschen nur das ist richtig dann
bringt schafft man die probleme wenn man
den jungen sagt ihr dürft keine sms im
dialekt ja wieso nicht sie dürften es
ist auch nicht so was da gesagt wurde
dass es früher überhaupt niemand je
einen satz in montag schon das wort ich
habe früher auch dinge in mundart
geschrieben und aneinander gesteckt aber
vielleicht neu das ist wirklich zu einem
vollwertigen sprachgebrauch also ich
entwickle ich möchte zum beispiel bei
lesungen gibt immer wieder leute die
sagen ich würde das buch gerne kaufen
aber ich kann nicht wundert lesen und
dass das auch ein junge der nicht mehr
jüngere und das ist eine komplett
entziehen können können montag lesen und
auch verschiedene montag
aber was ich noch fast interessanter
finden in diesem zusammenhang ist die es
wie sich die melodie zu verändern
beginnt also wir treten ja von diesem
bau kanzleien und wenn wir ihn hinhören
wie schweizer jugendliche hätten die
überhaupt sagen wir mal orthografisch
grammatikalische ein ganz korrekt ist
schweizerdeutsch reden aber eine andere
melodie haben die sagen so locker mit
hut und diese diese melodie entspricht
mich mit der gewohnten sprach noch die
das gibt dann ein interessanter kreative
möglichkeiten für den rat bei schon reif
für sie auch als als performer ist quasi
dann doch zwischen mundart höheren 100
räten nun das schreiben nun das lesen
das sind alles ganz verschiedene paar
schuhe ja ist jetzt also zb vor in der
journalist in diesem beitrag hat einen
ein satz gesagt dann wieder alles
selbstständig sagen denn ich habe nicht
unterschreiben würde ja gesagt reden wie
man denkt also die jungen schreiben wie
man denkt die schreiben dann wie man
denkt ja aber wer sagt denn dass ich
beim schreiben schweizerdeutsch denke
ich denke natürlich nicht immer
schweizer goalie mit seinem großer
erfolg ist jetzt ganz frisch übersetzt
kongenial von raphael urweider wie ihr
verlag schreibt damit auch ein größerer
markt sich entwickelt oder weil sie das
gefühl haben dass sie doch an eine
grenze gestoßen sind
die übersetzung ist eigentlich deshalb
erfolgt zum einen weil und weiter ein
mein freund ist und ein lyriker den ich
sehr schätze als lyriker und von dem ich
weiß dass er eine große musikalität im
alltag und in den händen
aber eigentlich ist es nicht gab sich
damit die welt zu haben sondern ich
wollte da die übersetzung aus einem
anderen grund wichtig ich wollte den
gegenübertreten die sagen mir hat ein
buch ist schön aber das hat das kann man
halt nur in hochdeutsch ein
schweizerdeutsch machen und nur weil du
das schöne beiden deutsch schreibst und
und ich konnte das nicht mehr hören weil
ich leide ich dachte ich hab' ich habe
da viel gearbeitet werden und ich werde
mich dagegen dass ein buch nur schön ist
weil er seit in einer bestimmten sprache
geschrieben ist und mit disney
übersetzungen kann ich vielleicht es
gibt ja noch eine auf italienische
machen eine französische total fertig
sagte machen sie selber habe weil ich
habe pro jahr hilft ja da auch und
vielleicht auch mal zeigen und in
persien hat das wunderbar glaubt sogar
bis nach italien dass das die leute die
die geschichte und den ton schätzen
unabhängig davon ob sie das schöne
berndeutsch
klingen lässt es ist natürlich ein
problem vermutlich natur generell es
gibt sozusagen diesen exotischen effekt
den die mundart auch innerhalb der
schweiz gibt auch irgendwie auch der
fordert dass das ist ja gut da so auch
sein aber es gibt auch die gefahr dass
einfach der dialekt für die
schriftsteller dichtet also dass die
effekte des dialekts ich sage der
tochter maria fekter es gibt so die ist
ja der eines der berühmtesten direkt
stück ein absoluter schweizer
staatsbürger liefern
franz hohler wo man kein wort versteht
aber das unglaublich toll findet weil es
einfach unseren jahre wieder gibt und
auf diesen effekt hin kann man natürlich
auch schreiben damit kann man auch
effekt haben aber das ist nicht
unbedingt die kunst ist auch nicht das
was pedro lenz das sind ganz zum schluss
fest tut mir leid die zeit rennt rennt
uns davon aber zum toten möglich was ist
eigentlich ihre lieblings 100 wird sagt
otten und die vielen dank für das
gespräch
[Musik]
dieses gespräch finden sie wenn sie
wollen jederzeit bei uns auf der website
oder aber sie bestellen die dvd war
bekannte adresse schweizer radio und
fernsehen redaktion sternstunden 80 52
zürich ihre e mail erreicht uns unter
sternen kombinat srf punkt ch heute in
einer woche
erinnern wir an fukushima in religion
und philosophie und in der kunst in der
sternstunde philosophie spricht barbara
bleisch mit dem risikoforscher gerd
gigerenzer und der ethikrat kirsten
meyer über das leben und erleben in
unsicheren zeiten risiko dass also unser
thema es kam zwar auch was der held
unseres folgenden filmes getan hat
riskant aber es hat sich unbedingt
gelohnt
eine reise in den westen usbekistans
hier am rande der ehemaligen sowjetunion
hat igor sawicki verbotene kunst gesamt
jahrzehntelang ein film über ein
einzigartiges museum
[Musik]